Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's the Monday morning podcast full Monday,
uh,
March 4th,
2013.
How you doing?
How's it going?
You like this?
Is it up early?
I hope it is because I'm recording it.
Uh,
on Sunday night right after watching the Bruins lose to the Canadians.
Let's get that out of the way.
Congratulations Canadians.
You guys,
Canadian fans.
You guys deserve to win the game.
Fucking Bruins.
Jesus Christ.
You had the gay man.
You
okay?
Oh my God,
they played,
they just fucking morons.
Okay.
They played like they just fucking played right into the Canadians hands.
We were up three to two for all.
You don't watch of,
um,
watch hockey.
We were up to three to two and even though it was three to two,
we were carrying the play and we had commanded the game and then,
uh,
the Canadian started getting chippy.
We fell right into it.
Fell right.
I got a good idea.
Chara take a fucking game misconduct day,
then I'll help the effort.
Okay.
I got to admit with nine minutes left,
I shut it off.
Once it was four to three,
I just shut the fucking thing off.
I was like,
it's,
you got to understand what the Bruins,
when Ciara is not on the ice,
it's like we pulled half our goaltender.
That's how important he is.
The place half the fucking game.
Yeah.
It was just a worse,
some fucking who gives a fuck player cross checks,
Sagan at the ice.
All right.
Whatever.
You know,
you don't like to see it,
but you're fucking go.
You got you take your head.
Can they take the helmet off?
What if they take the helmet off and then they start throwing punches?
At that point,
the D is still get the game is conduct.
I just don't understand how,
I just don't understand why you would do that.
Why would do you just basically gave them a 20 minute power play in the fucking
third period for the simple fact that one of the best defenseman in the league
and the best guy we have in all the ICA eats up,
but he's not even going to be out there.
Um,
very stupid,
but Canadians are much better team than they were last year.
It was a great game and the Canadians didn't play the traps,
so it was fucking awesome hockey.
And I was surprised with the amount of fucking Canadian friends giving me shit
on Twitter who don't even know what the fucking trap is.
I thought you guys came out of the womb with skates on,
you know,
go on Youtube.
They'll show you what the fuck it is.
You'll see those.
I don't know why they stopped playing in play when they played the penguins
either.
That was seven to six.
It was a fucking awesome game up.
That's what I like.
You know,
you don't just do one sports fan that I can't stand is the fucking person who
complains about some shit and then when his team does it,
he goes,
well I don't give a shit.
You know,
that's like what the Canadian fans are doing with the fucking trap.
Like they weren't crying was a with boredom when they watch the devil's trap way
to fucking three cups.
Yeah.
Were those not the most other than a Stevens was a great player to watch,
but other than I know a lot of people think he's dirty or whatever,
but I,
I've,
I've loved that guy.
But other than that,
I mean Jesus Christ.
I mean,
it was like,
I mean that we see almost the lose literally almost the end of the sport,
the whole,
the whole fucking game.
One team would skate to about mid ice.
They dumped the pocket and the goaltender could skate over the corner.
You don't try to wrap it around the boards.
The goalie could come over and stop it in the corner and then the defense would
bring it up the fucking ice.
Oh my God.
God forbid the other team was playing it two and then they'd fucking try to dump
and chase they called it.
Okay.
It,
it,
it was,
it was almost the end of the league and fucking Nhl.
For some reason,
NBA is smart enough to be like,
all right,
guys are too big.
They're too fast.
At the end of the day,
this sport is supposed to entertain fans and I don't watch enough hoop,
but I know that there's a legal defenses and hope for the fucking life of me.
I don't understand why the NHL just goes,
hey listen guys,
stop playing that shit.
All right.
Just fucking play the way they used to play.
You know,
and let's,
let's have some nice rushes in that type of shit.
Going up and down the ice,
couple of fights or whatever.
And let's get the fuck outta here.
So is that,
is that too hard?
Is that too hard?
It really gonna fucking get,
go up one goal and then sit back on your own fucking Blue Line of Waverly up
database.
A mistake.
Um,
I dunno,
I don't fucking know,
but I,
I really,
really disappointed in the Bruins for playing just right into their fucking
hands.
Sitting in like an old man screaming at the TV.
Now
back to the bench.
What are you doing?
Why would you do that?
I think last time I saw Ciara fight,
I think,
I believe last time I watched it was in buffalo and he was just in the box for
five fucking minutes.
And we immediately became like,
uh,
like,
you know,
we look like a a 500 team.
Um,
it's not as bad now because we got,
we've got some other guys back there on defense,
but Jesus fucking Christ.
So I gotta be honest with you,
I don't know what to to,
to take away from that game because I can't really say that we saw the Canadians
cause a price wasn't a net and uh,
you know,
and then shower takes that stupid fucking penalty.
So he didn't play a third of the game.
I Dunno.
I still think we're a better team.
So I feel good and I look at Montreal and that they look like a,
a second round of the playoffs going to get bounced out.
What's,
you'll make me happy then that'll be 22 seasons,
21 years without a cup.
And just with every year they look more and more like Matthew mcconaughey in
dazed and confused.
Like,
it's fucking over and they don't realize it yet.
You know,
I mean,
Jesus fucking Christ,
they still walk around arrogantly,
Canadian fence do like living off of like,
you know what they like at this point that like trust fund kids,
you know,
like their grandfather made all the money and now they're riding around this
Maserati that like interest paid for and then they are looking at you like this,
some sort of success and you're looking like,
dude,
you haven't done shit.
You haven't done shit in your life.
What do you puffing your chest out for?
You know,
in your high school jacket with all your grandfather's accomplishments written
up and down the fucking sleeves.
Do you remember that championship they won back in 1958?
You don't,
you can't.
Seriously,
you know,
I'll listen.
I'll take shift from Canadian fans that are like my age because I don't know
that they remember the,
uh,
the Patrick wa championships,
but these punks in their twenties right up to their early thirties.
You guys can all go fuck yourselves because I know you don't remember anything.
Even last time the Canadians won it.
You were upstairs in your lead jam jams,
you know,
getting ready to have some dreams.
So go fuck yourselves.
All right.
With your most overrated run of championships.
Oh,
let's start an argument here.
I'll ask you guys this.
What do you think
when I already congratulated the Canadians for winning,
right?
Did I do that?
So I'm not being a total country here.
I just love shitting on him.
Um,
what do you think is the most overrated,
overrated collection of like,
you know,
championships?
Uh,
the Celtics,
the Boston Celtics,
the 11 that they want in the 1960s,
uh,
the New York Yankees.
Oh,
the Montreal Canadians.
I would,
I would put them in this order.
I would say Canadians top of the list.
Then I would say Celtics.
And then I would say Yankees,
you know,
and this,
this is why,
okay.
The Canadians dominated a 16 league and they had first choice of every French
born Canadian player for like the first fucking 50 years.
It's like they had their own lottery draft every fucking year.
All right.
And that dimension,
there's five other teams.
I mean,
give me a fucking really,
you went on a run.
Holy Shit.
How did you do that?
You know,
then I would say,
I would say the only reason why I'm putting the Celtics next is because the
Yankees basically had Jordan.
They there,
there was such a good front office that they grabbed the Jordan three
generations in a row,
you know,
I mean we gave him fucking Babe Ruth like assholes because we wanted to have a
musical.
I think people should think too,
right.
So we give him babe Ruth,
but they had Lou Gehrig.
They went from Lou Gehrig,
Babe Ruth or Lou Gehrig to fucking Joe Dimaggio to Mickey Mantle.
Um,
there,
I don't,
I'm good.
I don't think you ever going to see that again.
That would be like if one team drafted a,
you went doctored,
the sixers got doctor j and then they fucking Michael Jordan and then they
drafted like Colby Bryant or Lebron,
like within like what does that like 30 years within 30 years from the 1920s,
the 1950s they had that.
So I put the Celtic second because I'm,
I know,
I guess it was a newer league.
Well the league started in the forties,
but it was still the 1960s.
It was still there was will Chamberlain but all those championships back then
though,
the amazing thing about it was the like the amazing argument.
It's like,
okay,
well it's distilled down.
So there's,
there's uh,
the talent level obviously should have been higher I guess.
But for some of you youngsters out there,
like back in the day when you won the pennant in baseball,
there was so few teams,
I should have done my research.
I used to know this shit.
There was like literally like maybe 17 in each,
um,
in each league.
So it was basically winning the pennant
was having the best record at the end of the regular season that was winning the
pennant.
And if you had the best record in the American league,
you immediately went to the world series.
There was no wildcard,
no divisional series,
and then the fucking a LLCs,
you immediately,
you went to the world series.
So basically after you won all those games in the regular season,
you had to win four more.
Um,
and I think that that's why you,
you saw teams go on.
I don't know.
I think that that's why you saw like a Yankees,
a Celtics or a,
a Canadian staying where they could go on runs because there was so,
there was way fewer teams and you had in even like the playoffs,
playoffs was,
was so much shorter.
Like I was talking to my buddy law yet,
he said,
yeah,
the amount of times that the Cleveland Indians won over a hundred games and they
didn't even make the playoffs because the Yankees had a couple more wins.
Um,
and you know how the playoffs go?
Anybody can fucking,
when you have a bad day or a bad couple of games,
next thing say,
know you bounced out in the first fucking round or a hundred wins,
go right down the toilet.
That didn't happen back then.
So,
uh,
I will be interested to hear,
but I mean,
I think obviously just the sheer number of teams and then that unbelievably
ridiculous advantage that the Canadians had that they had first choice of every
French board,
Canadian player,
you know,
I mean,
what the fuck?
Um,
but anyways,
anyways,
go and I,
and I promise you this,
that the Bruins ever start playing the trap.
I will immediately stop watching them,
uh,
because I,
I like the game of hockey.
I don't like watching it being suffocated.
All Right,
Bill,
you've made you God the employee.
How long did I talk about hockey?
And I can guarantee you there's no women left listening to this fucking thing.
11 minutes.
Does that sound all right?
I'm back to my old contraption here.
I bought yet another memory card.
Somebody on Twitter told me that the lovely zoom h four n recorder could take
one that had 32 gigabytes or some shit.
So I went out and I bought one of those and I stuck it in there and they said
that there was nothing in there.
So,
uh,
I don't know if I had a fish tank.
That's where this record would be at the bottom of it cause it kind of looks
like one of those castles that the goldfish swim swim in and out of.
Um,
all right,
let's get on with the podcast.
This is the Monday morning podcast.
Everybody.
I'm,
I'm actually in a great fucking move despite the fact that my Bruins lost.
Um,
have you ever had I was telling you how tight it showed me how to uh,
or basically did the job and then just stood over my shoulders.
I did the other one when we converted my front brakes from drum brakes to disc
brakes.
So I've had those drum brakes in my garage saying that I was going to put those
motherfuckers together and uh,
and they just been sitting there mocking me every time I'm walking by like,
what's up bitch?
What's up bitch?
What Titus isn't here to fucking hold your hand,
your little fucking pussy.
And we tell him we saw him,
they were bugging me.
So,
uh,
I went on,
I went on the Internet there,
I went to amazon.com.
That's what I did.
Everybody write through the Bill Berg website and the podcast page.
I clicked on it.
I actually got money kicked back to me that I'm going to kick on to the troops
and I bought the kit.
Um,
okay.
You know,
to help you put the fucking springs on and all that shit.
So underrated for this week.
Actually having the tools for the job that you need.
Cause I watched all these guys these weekend warriors going like,
you know,
there's just,
there's a special tool for this,
but if you don't have it,
uh,
you know,
a needle nose pliers,
we'll work,
get yourself a screwdriver and a no go out and get the fucking things that you
need.
And uh,
I actually got them all together.
I think I fucked up one of the springs.
I think one of them,
cause when I got told the last spring that was left,
it didn't seem like it fit right.
So I'm going to bring it down to the guy,
works on my truck normally and have him show me how to fucking do it.
But I was psyched.
I probably,
I'll put a picture up of what I,
what I have done so far.
I've got it basically three quarters done and I have some extra parts,
some clips and a couple of screws.
So I'm like 80% there.
And um,
I dunno,
I think I breathed in a bunch of,
especially this too.
I didn't realize actually I did and I was like,
Hey,
I'm outside,
I'm fine.
And then I've got this words,
I already had a scratchy feeling in my throat.
I thought I was catching a cold,
but now it feels like,
and it's best to see kind of cold.
Um,
okay.
But anyways,
man,
I'm,
I'm psyched.
I'm going to get these fucking things together.
Cause remember that carburetor I told you I took apart,
I tried and I was going to rebuild it.
I went nuts.
I took the whole fucking thing apart.
Right down to those,
those little flat,
it was a four barrel right down on those little flapper things.
I know what you call them,
but I took them out and now they won't fit back in.
Cause I think all the years of it just being so hot,
they were a little warped.
I can't get a back end.
So if anybody knows where I can buy those parts,
I don't mean like a rebuilt,
rebuilt kit.
I have all that shit.
I need the actual parts to the carburetor and a,
it's making me sick every time I look at it.
Um,
cause that's literally the first thing I have to put back together and I can't
get him.
I can't get them to fit.
Um,
so if anybody knows where I can order that shit,
I'd appreciate it.
All right.
What the fuck am I talking about this week?
Um,
you know,
I went to go look at a,
uh,
a story on the Internet that I somehow missed because I've been traveling so
much.
And one of the advertising,
the advertising before,
like the little youtube video was uh,
Oh,
before I forget,
I got,
I'm going to post the,
uh,
the youtube video of this southern dude who was doing the drum brakes on his
buddies Mustang that actually taught me how to do it.
The guy's a fucking riot.
He knows what he's doing,
but he's drinking the whole time and every time he takes a sip he goes chairs.
And it was,
he just,
he filmed it in real time,
so he fucked up,
you know,
a couple of times,
had to take some shit off.
You know,
you just put some shit on too soon or whatever and then,
you know,
kind of had to go back and forth.
But just watching a guy,
he just left the camera on.
It was really great.
So if you've ever thinking of doing it,
if a dumb ass like me configure it out,
sort of,
you know,
I'm not looking to lie to you.
I had some extra parts,
but after tomorrow when I go down in the garage,
the guy's going to show me what I did wrong and I'm going to have it down and
I'll do the other one and I know how to do it.
So I'll definitely post that video.
And,
um,
so anyways,
this advertising comes on right before this new story that I somehow missed.
And,
um,
it shows this guy out on a lake on a jet ski or something like that.
And these two ladies sitting on the bench on the beach,
I mean,
and they go,
uh,
she goes,
so when one of the lady says to the woman who's married to the guy and the jet
ski,
so does he still keep it in the driveway?
And she's like,
not any mar,
you know.
And like now that it's like in storage,
it was basically an advertising advertisement for storage,
right?
So of course,
you know,
the storage companies,
they're basically advertise into fucking ladies out there because what,
what a what a women do.
The second you get married to them,
you know,
they take over the fucking house.
And all your shit ends up out in the garage and if there's anything that sits in
the driveway,
how long before they want you to sell it?
You know what I mean?
Did they give a fuck that it's the last fucking flame flickering in your heart.
You know something.
You have a passion for an old car.
You want to fix up a fucking jet ski,
right?
And this fucking woman is sitting there gloating.
There's guys out on the lake cabin the fucking time of his life when this God
damn Jetski she sees how much she enjoys it.
Does she give a fuck?
No.
It's a fucking eyesore to her.
I really don't understand how women have like that motherly thing with,
they're like these absolute angels and at the same fucking time they,
they're like these,
I don't know what they are.
What is the fucking word?
It's not like a Leech.
They're like these,
uh,
okay.
I Dunno.
What does that old thing where a calf,
a cat sleeps on your chest,
it steals your life breath or something like that.
Or is that when you hold the milk in front of your mouth and a fucking tape worm
comes out,
I can't lose something of this sounds something somewhere in there.
Yeah,
somewhere in there.
There's,
there's a reference.
That would have been funny three minutes ago.
Sorry.
Um,
okay.
I just don't understand it.
That's why we need is this shit.
And he doesn't give a fuck.
I got my drum stuff,
my guitar stuff.
She knows I'm a big kid and she lets me have it.
She's never said,
oh,
why don't you take your shit and put it in storage,
you know?
But all these fucking women they show in these advertisings and all these
fucking sitcoms and shit.
I don't know.
I just don't understand it.
Why,
why?
You know,
at the end of the day,
you know who's fault it is.
It's the fucking guy in the jet ski.
You know when,
when she's sitting there breaking his fucking balls,
there's,
there's a great line that you can use when you're just sick of your woman.
She's just crossed too many lines and she's on a fucking role and she's gone.
And now I think,
yeah,
you get that yet.
And My mother is coming to town and he'd taking up all that space.
We need Rumford backyard a bunch.
She's on a fucking role.
There's a great simple thing that you could say to them,
you know,
to make them stop.
It's basically this all,
all right.
All right.
Okay.
That's what you do.
And then you sit in the awkward silence.
So you're yelling at me now?
Yeah.
Why are you doing that?
Because you're fucking annoying me.
Tell her,
cursing me.
I'm not cursing at you.
I'm cursing because I'm angry.
It's my fucking jet ski.
I enjoy it.
I like going out in the fucking leg,
doing little looky loose.
Oh,
little dosey doe,
whatever,
whatever the fucking slang is on jet skis.
I liked doing it.
Okay.
And I don't have to haul my ass all the way down to the fucking storage shed on
the other side of town.
Every time I feel like taking a lap around the lake.
Why don't we put some of your fucking shoes down there?
How about that?
No,
no.
Shut up shop while you're talking.
When I'm talking then that that's why that fucking word exists.
You shut your face lady.
All right.
My jet ski goes down to the Fucking,
uh,
storage center.
So to some of your,
your,
uh,
sort of some of your shoes.
Fucking only my jet ski.
Only my shit goes down.
They,
what kind of fucking lopsided trade is this?
Like I'm dismantling the team of my life.
Go Fuck Yourself.
You got to give somebody else to give somebody else up.
Okay.
There we go.
See that?
That's why,
you know,
I don't know if this,
this kind of shits gonna cause me to live longer,
uh,
dire earlier,
but literally that's what a 14 second advertisement can fucking do to me.
I get upset at this,
this hypothetical fucking relationship and this guy who was on this just jet ski
and goes into a green screen storage door.
I don't know if there's any women who's still listening to this.
Can you please answer me like two things.
What do you have against the guy you're with having fun without you?
And two,
what is it that guys do?
What is the male equivalent to doing that?
Because I know we balanced each other out at this point.
Okay.
But I'm,
I'm a guy,
so I only see,
you know,
I'm like a homer announcer.
I only see the fucking offenses that are on my side,
you know,
uh,
that affect me.
It really just,
just the way they said now,
begging is down,
crash this street.
Oh fuck you.
You,
he should just revved that engine and just fucking ran right over.
Nice propeller to the fucking cleavage.
That's disgusting.
Anyways,
anyways,
you know what?
I think that's a good times.
That's a nice setup for some advertising this week.
Oh,
Gigi.
22 minutes since some,
I'll tell you,
I'll tell you some weeks.
It's easy.
Some weeks it's hard.
It seems like it's going to be an easy one.
All right,
let's,
uh,
let's do the thing here.
Oh,
Christ.
Where is it?
Where have you gone?
Billy boy.
All right,
here we go.
All right.
Which one is this one?
Oh,
legal zoom.com.
Everybody.
Guess what?
It's national biz national starch.
Your business month.
I thought last month was that,
well,
you know what legal zooms killing.
It's so hard.
Every month should be national legal zoom.
No national starch your business month.
Do I have dyslexia?
Um,
let's start over again.
Once again,
it's national starch,
your business month@legalzoom.com.
Okay.
I know I've been talking about this for more than a month,
but so many,
oh they already,
they already had it covered.
But so many of you are starting businesses right now.
So legal zoom has decided to extend it through March.
You liked that.
So that's the kind of power legal zoom has.
Okay.
They'll like Bloomberg,
you know the terms up and they're still going.
They're still an office.
That's,
there's so much is these guys are killing it.
Call it whatever you want.
Just to remember that this is a great time to start your business.
Whether you're starting up an LLC,
an s Corp Sole Proprietorship or a nonprofit legal zoom takes care of you from
stat to finish their award.
Wedding service was developed by the best legal minds in the country and every
business gets personalized attention.
That's why over 90% of legal zoom customers would recommend the service to their
family.
Uh,
you'll be in good company,
three dozen companies and on the INC 500 list,
we're started through legal zoom.
Start Your Business right@legalzoom.com legal zoom is not a law firm and provide
self help self services at your specific direction.
In other words,
if you're having a problem,
call them up and their law team will help you.
Uh,
but there's so much more now.
Every LLC and a corporation package includes easy use business accounting
software at $269 value for absolutely free.
Be sure to enter bur bur are and the referral box at checkout.
Start Your Business,
protect your family,
and safeguard your assets at legal zoom today.
All right,
and of course the classic,
the classic stamps.com stamps.com.
Where the hell is it?
Where is it?
Where have you gone?
stamps.com where have you gone?
You've last the whole day long.
You know what?
I was a kid.
The first record.
My mother got me with single,
with Mitch Miller and the gang did ever tell you that I've sung those before.
Right?
I,
you know,
led Zeppelin was putting out albums at that time,
Aerosmith was just starting out,
ac DC,
David Bowie,
James Brown,
who else was putting out albums when I got that,
it was insane.
I guess Jimi Hendrix,
Joplin and Morrison had just died.
Jackson five and it just,
all these amazing artists and my mom comes home with sing along with Mitch
Miller and the gang is everybody at school knew all these cool songs and I'm
walking around and going five foot to wise,
up blue,
but oh,
what those five puts good.
Has any body shame?
My Gal that if you run into a five two covered with pearls,
bum,
diamond rings and all those things,
you bet your life.
It isn't her.
But could she loved,
could she cool?
Could she could she could [inaudible] seed my and my hair.
It was orange.
Is it any,
is it any wonder?
I ended up doing this shit,
talking to myself in the basement of my fucking home.
Oh by the way,
I finally got the roof put on my house.
Love in life as one of those things that you absolutely love and your girl could
give a fuck about.
I'm standing up there,
you know,
just staring at it,
talking to Nia.
Look at it.
Look at the fucking top paper.
Right?
She could give a shit.
She's like,
yeah,
yeah.
It's nice.
It's very nice.
It's going to keep it like 15 degrees cooler.
We used to have the black,
now it's a white that was white.
You know,
it's going to reflect light rather than attracting.
Do you understand what's going on?
Yeah,
that's tar paper.
All right.
stamps.com everybody.
You know,
it's funny.
Everyone who fast forwarded through the ads,
just miss me singing that song.
stamps.com everybody.
Uh,
odds are you're most productive when you're working from your desk.
So leaving just to go to the post office can slow you down.
You can also get stuck in traffic.
You can have a flat tire.
God knows how many can rear end you.
You know,
somebody could point it.
You went to what police officer's going.
That's the guy.
That's the guy who did it right.
Then you got to get a lawyer,
you know?
That's why you need stamps.com with stamps com you can buy print,
buy and print official US postage right from your own computer and printer and
nobody can accuse you for a,
for a crime he didn't commit.
stamps.com we'll send you a digital scale.
Automatically calculates the exact posted you need for any letter or package,
any class of male.
You'll never waste valuable time going to the post office again,
do everything right from your desk with stamps.com print postage you need put it
on your letter or package.
Just hand it to your mail carrier and you're done.
I use stamps.com to send out all my DVDs.
I just did it this week.
Show easy.
Even this moron can do it right now.
Use My last name bur bur for a special offer,
no risk trial plus $110 bonus offer includes digital scale and up to $55 free
postage.
Don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone at the top of the poem page and type in Burpee.
You are that stamps.com enter burr.
And there we go.
There we go.
Won't you come Home Bill Bailey,
won't you come home?
That's what I would be singing.
Everybody else was singing,
you know,
like sweet emotion and I'm walking around going roll out the barrel.
What lab?
A barrel of fun.
We got it.
Bill,
you'll listen to a bad record.
All right.
So anyways,
here it was a new story that I sudden somehow missed out on.
Um,
I've been living a very,
a cavernous life recently.
Um,
I've been really busy so I've missed out on a lot of,
uh,
okay.
A lot of stories.
I don't,
how the fuck did I miss out on this?
And Jim Norton actually did a bit about this on the Patrice O'Neal benefit and I
missed it cause I was,
I was in the back somewhere and making sure,
you know,
freaking out,
making sure everybody had food and all that dynamic range.
One of those things before.
So,
you know,
I was,
uh,
it was like that fucking nerd who,
who had a party and was worried that no one was going to show up or they'd show
up and say,
that sucked.
I guess he did a story on this.
It's an a man charge was slapping a toddler on a Minneapolis to Atlanta flight
is out of a job.
This guy got up and he slapped a baby and the baby was African American and he
dropped the n word.
Okay.
I mean,
I've been trying to fig like that's gotta be like as far as ending your career,
that's like just,
I mean,
I don't know how you could've done it any better.
Like if you truly just wanted to get fired,
I mean,
you could have stopped with slapping a baby.
That is Jay,
let me,
that is just,
I can't,
I'm,
can you fucking,
you haven't been on a plane.
The baby starts crying.
I always get blown away by people who get annoyed by it.
I always find it funny and relatable.
Like when I hear a baby start crying,
I just think like,
I just,
I'm,
I'm jealous of the freedom of it.
I want to do that too.
Like how great that would be.
Just anytime.
It just,
life started to suck.
He doesn't do that.
You know how all my God,
I should be like verse pullovers he has a bit just so I gotta stop paupers
versus he has a bitches like this.
Oh wait,
I gotta stop here.
Go See Paul Versey for the rest of this fucking ideas.
Oh my God.
Accidentally almost stumbled into that one.
Um,
but I've,
I've always felt that though.
Okay.
Can you fucking believe going up?
It's slapping.
Forget the whole racial thing.
Just standing up.
I mean,
we've all had a couple of drinks.
We've all said some things.
You know,
how many fucking drinks do you have?
Well,
you,
your brain goes,
why don't you go over there and slap that bitch fucking head?
I can see if you were driving by and there was a baby standing on the street
corner and you took the plates off your car,
I could see in your drunk mind thinking that you are going to get away with
that.
But this guy,
if you did that in the mall,
it would be over.
This guy does it on a plane.
There's no where to go.
There's nowhere to go.
Okay.
Yeah.
You know what,
when they make the sequel to like snakes on a plane,
they sh this is what it should be.
It should be Sam Jackson is a baby in some racist white guy slaps him in the
face and,
and calls him the n word and then that it just sets him on.
That guy's actually part of the Illuminati.
I'm just throwing shit against the wall.
That guys,
part of the Illuminati and the reason why he's on a commercial airline flight
is,
uh,
maybe he got a little too out of control at the last secret meeting.
He didn't do the handshake.
Right.
You know,
and the,
as a punishment,
he actually had to fly commercial like FirstClass and uh,
okay.
And it's actually it's a baby Sam Jackson.
Okay.
And,
and it's whatever snakes on a plane.
Snakes meaning like the Illuminati,
like they're pieces of shit snakes on a plane,
part two.
And in the the tag is you just slapped the wrong motherfucker.
I'm sorry.
Sometimes this shit's just funny to me,
but um,
oh and then he drops the n word.
I mean Jesus,
I mean this guy is just like,
it's just as far as evil,
it would be like,
I can't even imagine.
It would be like getting eaten by a snake and a shark at the same time.
Like I wouldn't be possible.
Like the level of evil that is in that man's heart.
Yeah.
You know,
Jesus,
I'm trying to like,
he's sick.
He's a 60 year old guy from Idaho
and I even think the 60 is too young at this point to still be dropping the n
word.
You know,
you get somebody at this point,
let's see,
60 years old,
you were black,
you know,
Nah,
you were born in the fifties come on man,
you're born to fit.
You should know better.
All right.
Even white guy in the middle of nowhere,
you should know better.
So I feel like the,
the the white person dropping the n word kind of Shit,
even though I know there's a bunch of hate groups out there,
I'm just talking to the average everyday Joe just on a fucking plane saying that
type of shit.
That's like a,
you know,
at this point I think you,
you were born in like the twenties and the thirties maybe the forties may Bill
Clinton was in the forties right?
He's played saxophone on our Cineo Hall.
I don't even did the cool handshake.
Right.
White people have come a long way.
This guy just set white people back.
The only thing that's saved that he's an old white guy and I think people always
just look at old people is like they were born in the 18 hundreds at least I do.
Maybe that's me cause I'll be 45 this year and I just realized that I'm 15 years
away from being 60 years old.
And you know what,
I'm all right with that.
You know,
I make salads,
I'm doing pull ups,
go fuck yourself.
All right.
Um,
it's not like I'm aging any quicker than anybody else.
We all listen,
we all get a day older every day.
Okay.
Now the great thing about being my age is if the fucking we get hit by an
asteroid,
I got 45 years in.
All right,
you only got 20 [inaudible] but they're,
they're great.
20 years,
your first 20,
now they think of it.
You don't have to deal with a bunch of other shit that you,
I don't know.
But let's does this,
this is kinda gone off the rails here.
Um,
so I apologize.
Like I really missed out on a bunch of stories.
I don't,
I just kind of,
obviously as you can tell from the first 11 minutes of this podcast,
all I do is watch hockey and then try and put together auto parts while
breathing in a [inaudible],
um,
embattled,
Scottish,
Cardinal O'Brien,
Cardinal O'brien apologizes for my sexual conduct.
You know,
I'm getting sick of people apologizing for shit and they dance around this guy
basically to use my new word,
he buggered some kids.
All right?
He took out his holy Cock Oleo and stuck it in their fucking,
uh,
what the fuck was Jesus born in a shed?
What are they always call it,
you know,
are always around Christmas.
I remember what it's called.
What was he boys born in a barn,
but they give it some biblical,
what's the name for a Biblical Barn?
I don't give a fuck.
Anyways,
it says the Scottish cardinal who had earlier earlier challenged allegations of
his sexual impropriety claims that once again claims that once again shine an
international spotlight and the alleged alleged sexual abuse evolving row
involving Roman Catholic clergy reverse course Sunday.
And the guy,
I apologize,
this is how we apologizes for basic I for as far as I can tell,
fucking children in the ass.
He said,
I wish to take this opportunity to admit that there have been times that my
sexual has fallen below the standards expected of me as a priest,
archbishop and Cardinal.
Yeah.
In recent days,
certain allegations which have been made against me have become public initially
there are anonymous and nonspecific nature led me to contest them to those I
have offended.
I apologize and ask forgiveness to those.
I've offended.
You know,
I've been lucky enough in my life to have never been unwantedly fucking banged
in the ass by a fucking priest.
But I know,
I think I can be empathetic enough and say that if this was happening,
at no point would I be turning around going,
you know,
that's what you're doing is really offensive.
I find this,
you know what the fuck?
Yeah.
When you apologize,
you should have to say what the fuck you did.
And if you're going to talk like this,
there should be somebody obnoxiously yelling off the mic like what you did like
during this paulagy should have been like,
I wish to take each opportunity to admit that there have been times that my
sexual conduct has fallen below the standards expected of me as a priest.
Yeah.
And it's a fucking human being.
You're not supposed to fuck kids.
And regent days,
certain allegations fucking of children which have been made against me have
become public.
Bob Flock and tie and naturally there are not miss and nonspecific nature led me
to contest them how many different ways.
So we got them explain it.
You talk to your fucking Dick to put in their ass.
You got the point.
Um,
okay,
good lord to those.
I have offended to those you're raped.
You're a fucking rapist.
And like,
like how like he tries to tie in the fact that he's a priest
like below the standards expected of me as a priest,
Archbishop,
archbishop and Cardinal.
Yeah.
So like
what if you,
if you were a pope that was okay or was it because you never became a pope?
So these guys basically been dental and kids ever since he got into that fucking
hurt.
How is that thing still in business is just fucking beyond me.
Um,
anyways,
so that's the news for this week.
Everybody.
I hope you enjoyed it.
Um,
let's get on with some sort of a,
uh,
what do we got here?
Did I talk about everything I want to talk about?
Yeah,
I think I did.
Alright,
cool.
new girl.
Hey Bill.
Love your calamity and just wanted to ask a clarifying question.
My guy always gives me crap for watching the show new girl.
Uh,
due to the fact that he thinks the show is ridiculous.
He refuses to believe that you did a spot on it.
Can you please verify whether or not you on a show is Nick's cousin?
I know you're a busy guy,
but I listened to your podcast and know that you respond personally to emails,
which is great.
Um,
I can neither confirm nor deny that that is top secret information.
And I'm not allowed to talk about it.
Um,
but chances are good.
Yeah.
I did an episode of the,
I did an episode of it,
uh,
two weeks ago.
MMM.
Does that help you win your argument?
Will that make your boyfriend like the show more?
I doubt it.
Uh,
he thinks to show is ridiculous,
so he refuses to believe that I did a spot on it.
Well,
tell him this.
I did a spot on it and everybody in the show was fucking hilarious and I had a
great time.
And I also got to work with Nick Kroll who had me dying laughing between every
take.
I was laughing like a school girl,
so I had a great time on the shelf.
It's unfortunate your boyfriend can't enjoy the show,
but do you know what,
that's why there's other shelves.
Um,
but I actually liked how your,
your boyfriend views make that I am big enough to actually turn down acting
work,
having one day sit down and read my IMD be page and eight seconds later when
he's finished,
I would do a pilot of a show that was ripping off sesame street.
And I would play the lower half of big bird at this point.
I don't give a fuck.
Um,
so if I get to be on a hit show like that,
yeah,
absolutely.
Oh,
I had a great time.
I had a great time on that show.
And uh,
you know,
just tell you boyfriend,
he doesn't have to watch it.
All right.
Hey Bill,
I'll keep this short,
but my wife had three years cheated on me back in July.
Oh,
Jesus.
While she did it three years in,
please don't have any kids.
Please don't have any kids.
After telling her that I wanted to work things out,
she fucking left me for another dude in November.
Not even the dude she cheated on me with.
Um,
man.
Yeah,
that's one of those deals where you still loved her and she just fucking hit you
with a giant bucket of water and you were in shock.
Um,
so you tried to work it out with that cheating whore.
Uh,
anyways,
he said,
uh,
I was friends with this girl since high school,
as was her.
Wait a minute.
I was friends with this girl since high school as was with her now and was with
her.
You wrote as Anne was with her for a total of six years and she broke,
broke off our marriage via text.
Okay.
What a fucking cunt.
Anyways,
I'm 30 years old in great shape,
live on my own,
have been on a dating website for a couple of months and I've yet to go out on a
date with anyone because I secretly think all these girls just like getting guys
to look at their online profiles but never want to go out on a date.
My question is should I continue to try and find someone through online dating
or somewhere else?
I've only been with two girls my entire life and want to take your advice and
get it out of my system for a bit before I settled down with someone else.
Yeah,
do it.
Why don't you,
first of all,
you're only 30 years old,
which is really young nowadays.
Why don't you give yourself a little bit of time to heal from what the hell you
just went through before you jump into something else.
Learn a little bit about yourself,
figure out what you're looking for and what you,
what you want.
What's a deal breaker,
what is something that you want,
you know,
you're looking for.
And then I would go into a relationship like that.
Um,
I online dating I think is great.
I mean,
if I was a young guy,
I would do that in a second.
I mean,
that's just like,
all of a sudden you become like the bill Bellacheck a pussy,
you know,
it's like you got your own draft.
It's like,
it's like you're looking at the,
the fucking,
the NFL combine,
you know,
but instead of seeing their vertical leap,
you'll,
you're looking at like a,
the teddies,
I don't know what you do and the thing,
but um,
look,
it could have been a lot worse.
She could've done it like when you were 40 and you already had a couple of kids
and you'd have to pay for a cheat and asked to,
um,
I think the fact that you guys were young when you got married,
I don't think she knows how to break up with somebody.
She probably deliberately sabotage the relationship.
And the fact that she sent a text,
she doesn't like confrontation.
She still very immature.
Um,
so what are you going to do?
But whatever she's in the rear view mirror,
I would,
okay.
You know,
the best revenge is living a great life.
So take some time.
Go travel,
go fucking,
I don't know.
I'll do something for now to fly a helicopter,
ride a motorcycle,
go to Europe,
you know,
go,
go to a Superbowl,
both some cash,
just to something for yourself,
figuring out what you want to do and uh,
just tell women you're not ready to get into something until you are.
That's it.
And be totally 100% honest.
I'm going to call me back.
I thought he had a good time.
I had a great time,
but I didn't feel that feeling like you were the one.
I'm sorry.
You know,
Bang,
boom real fucking quick.
And uh,
you know,
the second year,
honest like that,
that's when you'll eventually find the person you're supposed to be with when
you keep lying to people.
Cause you don't want to hurt their feelings.
You just end up hurting yourself.
So sorry you went through that.
Um,
but uh,
you know what dude,
it's your,
it's your time right now.
So enjoy yourself.
All right.
Doris,
Bill ex-girlfriend won't x.
What does that mean?
Won't exit.
Uh,
I need some advice on how to handle a crazed woman.
Oh,
Jesus.
I Dunno dude.
This is rough.
A crazed woman.
Uh,
I'm 18 and have joined the marine corps and I leave for basic and a few months.
While Jesus is a great out
as a way to get out of a relationship,
you know,
I'd love to keep seeing you,
but I uh,
I joined the marines.
Yeah,
sorry about that.
I know.
It's crazy.
All right.
See you.
Anyways,
he said,
I've been dating this girl for about six months in,
dumped her because I feel like the last thing I need when I'm away is a
relationship with someone who will never see
exactly.
The girl has constantly been blowing up my phone for the past couple of weeks.
Uh,
I thought she would calm down over time,
but it seems to be getting worse.
I started to get really concerned when I arrived home the other day and she was
at my house talking to my mother,
who thinks this girl is the greatest thing that ever happened to me.
How can I get this girl
out of my life?
Any advice?
Uh,
would be greatly appreciated.
Love the podcasts.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Um,
all right,
well what this is,
I,
you get a ride.
He's like,
if you just don't answer any of our calls,
all right.
And you know,
she shows up where you're at.
Just say,
leave me alone.
I don't want to talk.
And just,
you know,
eventually,
I mean,
you can't get blood from a stone.
And I would immediately talk to me your mother and just say,
listen,
I know you love this girl,
but,
uh,
I don't just,
this is going to be the mother of my kids and she's stalking me.
Okay?
So I need you to not talk to her.
And then that's it.
Start with that.
And then after that,
um,
I don't know where you go after that stun gun.
I don't know.
Did you go to the Marines?
So it's so it's going to be fucking over.
When did you say leaf?
A basic and a few months.
Yes.
Tell your mother to stop talking to her.
She say she's fucking nuts and uh,
yeah,
that shouldn't be that hard.
I mean she,
she's just blowing up your phone.
You know,
she's not pinging in the batter of the brownies that you then eat with your
fucking best friend.
Right.
Like last week.
Um,
anyways,
new pope a Boston.
Billy loved the podcast.
Keep up the good work.
Thank you.
What do you make of all this news about the pope retiring?
Oh Geez.
Geez.
Personally I'm not that religious and don't really care that much.
Maybe if they elected a new pope that was young.
Well that was a young,
some young hot lady in her twenties.
I would give a shit.
What do you think bill?
Is there more to the story that,
that they're not telling us where his age and health issues.
The only reason he retired is the church covering anything up.
Um,
I'll come on and do what do they cover?
Anything up.
They,
they fucking have been an aisle.
Certain percentage of them have been covering up other fucking kids
for a long time.
You know,
during World War Two there was a,
you know,
they got in bed with the Nazis.
I mean,
it really is one of the worst organization as far as some of the shit that
they've done,
you know,
but people are so wrapped into not pissing off the invisible guy and wanting to
go to the happy place and get to eat marshmallows for the rest of you fall
fucking eternity.
That they are actually,
it's really,
it's,
it's disturbing.
Yeah.
That people can still be part of that religion.
You don't want him,
I don't understand how,
you know,
the stuff that they've done.
So,
uh,
yeah,
I would say,
there's probably something going on.
I don't know,
maybe he said something like a,
Hey,
you know,
ah,
maybe we should apologize for,
uh,
having that clam bake with Adolf Hitler.
Should we maybe clear the air with that one?
Hey,
what do you say?
Yo,
we actually don't help to pay for the lawyers of the people in our organization
who put their dicks in the acids of kids.
You know?
Maybe he said something like that.
I have no idea.
Anyways,
she said also,
what are some of some of the ways that they could make the church more
interesting?
For example,
maybe let broads,
but
I bet more people would pay attention.
Or how about letting people sit in lazy boys instead of sitting and kneeling and
those terrible rock hard benches they call pews.
I know.
It's so dumb.
The whole thing is to get you like you're not worthy.
You're not worthy.
Get on your fucking knees and it's in.
It's all,
it's all made up by human beings taking a guest and other adults because they
get into it.
His kids,
they,
I don't know why.
I actually know why because I believe that there was like a spirituality and I
believe that you feel good when you do good things.
And I just think that you can't corral that nobody owns it and you can't put a
fucking,
like,
I think that all churches should just be philosophies rather than this,
this hardened way of looking at things.
Um,
just the amount of death that it has caused.
I don't,
I'm not saying anything fucking,
do you guys know how I feel on this shit?
Um,
finally,
how about we live in up the music a bit and add some newer sounds.
Maybe a little guitar and drums.
Well,
what you need to do is go to a Baptist church,
go to a church where you don't see any white people going in there.
Um,
that,
that would be a good one to start with.
And I bet you're amazing.
You'll,
you'll hear people who are actually in those churches probably sing bay better
than half the people who won grammys that year.
I mean,
how many times you've seen some amazing created whore sticking her finger in a
year.
La Trying to act like they know how to sing and what do they,
what's behind them all the fucking time.
It's always like fucking three black chicks or two black chicks is some black
dude.
I mean that's where the music is.
That's where it's coming from us.
That's what you want.
Just fucking go there.
They're not going to give a shit.
Right.
They might look at you weird,
but after a while,
once to see you feel the music,
you should be fine.
You should be fine.
The rest of the shit,
I don't know.
I think that they should maybe update the stories.
Okay.
Every once in awhile
maybe,
uh,
just make up some new shit.
Just say,
Oh,
you know what,
God,
God came back again and the burning Bush said,
uh,
you know,
let he who never,
uh,
illegally downloaded the song.
Just something to fucking update it.
I don't know what to tell you.
You know what I mean?
I don't know.
Updated,
I guess,
you know,
there are some sort of,
some of those new age,
the new age ones
are just as scary because then somehow somebody always ends up saying there,
Jesus,
and the next thing you know,
you're surrounded by the FBI and his tank shooting flames at Ya.
Or you're waiting for some aliens to come.
And next thing you know,
everybody's drinking some poison and you're dying of fucking bunk bed,
you know?
Or in the middle of the jungle with some sweaty fucking Conga player,
whatever the fucking that guy's name was.
Okay.
You know,
I think you better.
It's when it comes to us,
spirituality and that type of shit,
I think you're really,
you're better off on your own.
MMM.
I think,
you know,
I think generally speaking,
if you're not a psycho,
you kind of know how to be a decent human being.
I'm not saying that you're always succeed in it.
I certainly don't.
But,
um,
how the fuck do I put it?
I would rather sit at a bar about six,
seven beers in and talk to somebody else who's in the same mind frame and talk
about life than I would to actually go to a church and listen to some guy up
there going,
eh.
Then he did stop day Gaddy,
did something,
Aus,
he did it for you.
He died painfully.
I hope you appreciated.
And then I lay low ya'll ya'll way we are.
You're not fucking worthy.
We want you to remember this.
Your a piece of shit.
You better hope he's not mad at you.
I lay Lou.
Yeah,
I'll lay Lou.
I mean who the fuck wants to sit there through that?
I mean there's still telling stories about lepers.
Can we fucking update it?
You know
the world was flat.
Now the world is flat and there was some lappers and a guy at a big Bodie stuck
some animals on,
what am I singing?
I don't even know.
I shouldn't have listened to my mother.
Like how do you,
how do you end up in that?
Okay,
here's a job where you,
you're not going to be able to ever fuck another woman again.
You know?
Well,
do I get a wife?
No,
you don't get that.
You're going to sit in his dorm room with a bunch of other guys.
None of you are beginners.
They're going to get any pussy whatsoever.
Okay?
There you go.
There's a natural,
like the whole thing is just like,
as far as the Catholic way is just like,
just flogging yourself.
Do you understand how fucked up,
but you got one fucking life.
You should be out having the time of your life,
you know,
not hurting anybody,
but having the time you life and enjoying it because you fucking deserve it
because you were lucky enough to be born a human being and not a fucking house
fly.
What if reincarnation is all right and you're going to fucking come back?
Is is a,
uh,
I don't know.
Something.
A snake.
Each
one of those little fucking lizards sitting at darting around.
Any of you don't get eaten by a snake.
He only lived like 14 days.
You can fucking drive a car.
You know,
you never see a lizard doin that shit.
Do.
Ah,
Jesus,
this is best as fucking with me.
Um,
hey,
everybody gets where I'm going this week.
I'm in beautiful downtown fucking Los Angeles,
enjoying my life right now and this wonderful weather,
you know,
and you're probably thinking like,
hey bill,
last thing you want to do is go to Wisconsin and Michigan.
And you know what I say?
Fuck you.
That's exactly where I am going.
I'm going to Wisconsin,
the great state of Wisconsin and I am then going on to Michigan.
I am doing a bunch of shows this weekend as you can tell by how long it's taken
me to tell you this.
I'm opening my website.
I'm going to be at the Barrymore theater in Madison,
Wisconsin on March 7th,
uh,
with uh,
opening act Wisconsin zone,
nay Craig,
his triumphant return to the Greater Madison,
Wisconsin area.
Um,
on March 8th,
I will be knewing not one,
but two shows at the legendary beautiful,
absolutely gorgeous PAPP's theater in Milwaukee,
Wisconsin.
Um,
if you live in that area and you've never been to the theater,
you know,
you should write,
you should come down,
see the show at the very least.
Just look at the,
uh,
the beautiful etchings on the wall.
On March 9th,
I will be doing the,
uh,
Albeit Fountain Street church in Grand Rapids,
Michigan,
part of the,
uh,
there's a comedy festival out there.
I don't have the name of it on my,
uh,
website March 9th and March 10th.
I will be,
uh,
right outside of Detroit at the Royal Oak Music Theater for not one,
but two shows on March 10th.
So that's it.
That's the deal.
I'm going to visit winter for four days and it's going to be a great time.
And if you guys know any,
uh,
any great places to eat out there,
places you know,
Shit that I should definitely get him.
You got to get yourself a horse shoe.
Have you had a juicy Lucy?
Whatever the fuck you have out there,
a sandwich,
a drink of fucking buffalo wings,
whatever you got.
I want to know.
Um,
all right.
That's it.
Where the hell are we?
55 minutes in.
I can't stop this early.
Oh,
okay.
Let me tell you this story here.
Uh,
last night I had a,
uh,
I did this great thing,
this,
um,
the fuck is my phone.
I lose my phone already.
You guys like me.
Do you lose your phone like fucking 20 times a God Damn Day?
What's the deal with Lulu Moon?
Um,
what am I trying to say?
Okay.
Last night,
ah,
this is fucking goddamn thing enough already.
Last night I did a skyway comedian.
Wayne Fetterman does this great
film festival every year and he picks like four or five comedians and they all
basically talk about of a film that influenced them as a comedian or just
wanting to get into show business.
So whatever.
And uh,
they have the comic talk about it before and then they show the movie.
And um,
the night I was down there,
nick
crawl went down and he did raising Arizona.
I'm sitting out in a crowd and the movie's just fucking killing and I'm laughing
and having a great time wherever I go down the street.
And,
uh,
I picked the,
I picked the dirty dozen,
you know,
I loved that movie.
All of a Victor Franco.
I just,
I just loved that,
that the attitudes at the dirty dozen guys had where they just kind of,
I don't appeal to me as a kid.
Like they did,
they,
they were fighting it like a,
they had issues with authority.
You know,
I didn't like teachers.
I didn't like my parents going,
hey,
get in there,
clean up your fucking room.
I just never liked it.
So the movie appealed to me and what I didn't realize is that movie is 150
minutes long.
So if anybody,
only five people walked out.
We started the fucking movie.
I don't know when we started with the show was supposed to start at 10,
15.
I know it may,
it had to have started a little bit late.
We did do a Q and.
A,
which was a lot of fun and I don't know when the movie started,
but it,
it,
it ended at like 10 past one in the morning and I was sitting in the back and I
literally felt like it was my movie and it was bombing people still enjoyed it
because it was,
you know,
movie festival.
It's like movie geeks and that type of thing.
But my apologies to anybody there who wanted to leave but didn't want to be rude
because I was sitting there in the back just for to be empathetic.
My ass fell asleep to,
I can't pull,
I never remember it being that fucking long.
The middle of that movie,
the whole thing where they have the war games.
I mean,
I think they shot that in real time.
They could have done that so much quicker.
MMM.
Hundred and 50 I what is that?
Two hours
30 that's two and a half hours long.
MMM [inaudible]
but anyways,
I,
you know,
I kept wanting to leave out of embarrassment because I just kept feeling like
everyone was getting tired and they weren't enjoying it.
But I was also going like,
wait,
I get to see the dirty dozen on a big screen.
So,
uh,
but Wayne assured me that everybody had a great time and they loved the movie
and
uh,
I dunno,
it was a,
it was definitely a fun time.
So if you're ever out here in la,
this time of year,
I guess every year,
Wayne Fetterman does it at the silent movie theater on Fairfax Avenue when I
think that's about it.
Ladies and gentlemen,
that is the podcast for this week.
Uh,
like I said,
I'll be at Wisconsin and I'll be in Michigan if you guys know of any places to
eat out that way that I should check out.
Uh,
I try to stay out of trouble when I'm on the road,
but if there is a great bar that you know of,
maybe a check one out,
like grand rapids,
what does it do in grand rapids?
I don't know that I've been out to that one.
Whatever.
You guys will figure it out.
That's the podcast for this week.
Go fuck yourselves.
Oh lastly,
last thing I have here,
sorry,
the USP Bestos is kicking in.
I finally have the hard copy.
I'm literally making the shape of the DVD,
like one of the corners with my hand for some reason in front of my face so I
can find the word in my speced this logged head.
Um,
I finally had the hard copy versions of uh,
my,
my special that came out last year.
You people are all the same.
Um,
I'll be selling those in uh,
Wisconsin and in Michigan already signed all of them and ship them out through
stamps.com and a every show after this I will be selling those motherfuckers
cause I've got about 200 boxes of him sitting in my garage,
taken up space.
So,
uh,
if you want to buy the hard copy version of it,
come out to my show and eventually we're going to get them up hopefully sooner
rather than later on the website.
And um,
I really appreciate it if you buy one and if you don't,
if you've already downloaded one,
whatever.
Thanks for listening and all that shit.
All right,
go fuck yourselves.
We'll talk to you next week.